i've been listening to your music and
i've been stalking you on instagram and
i will say you've been very active
i'm seeing mountain biking i'm seeing
paintballing
no place would rather be than on the
road with our fans but
you know there's been some silver
linings for sure as far as um being a
lot of times my wife
my kids who i miss a lot when i'm on the
road i've got great kids they're 12 10
and seven
very active it's nice living in a place
where i can keep them active outdoors a
lot
i love that you joked that paintballing
was like couples therapy for you and
your wife yes
i strongly recommend it what does
paintball cost like 30 bucks it's money
well spent um
especially if you've been kind of a jerk
or you know your wife needs to take some
stuff out on you in a way that's not
going to kill you
made her very happy and unsurprised i
was surprised how happy she was i mean
she really got a lot of joy out of like
making me bleed it's been fun uh but i
am looking forward to uh
going into the studio to start working
on a new record i've been writing songs
all
year oh
[Music]
what inspired your single bond well i
love the title
because everything i love is gone you
know there's no touring and fans and
gigs so i love that but i didn't want to
write a song or sing a song about coven
nobody wants to hear that but the song's
actually about a relationship
and it's written in a clever way where
the girls she left but it's actually the
guy that's gone you know he hasn't gone
anywhere
like all of us i've been sitting on the
couch watching tv
all day long all day long
i've been trying to figure out how a
good thing
went wrong i love the homage to the tv
sitcoms in the music video so
yeah what was your favorite sitcom back
in the day
oh my gosh back the day i loved all
those shows that were on there macgyver
is a huge macgyver fan i
mean that get a chance to play macgyver
in the video it was really fun for me